[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
by the way i want to get you some up dog
someone buddy
some up dog
what's up dog not much what's up with
you doc
[Laughter]
that's like a fourth grade joke i think
fourth grade at least maybe this i don't
know i'm not sure which one
i know this guy
he picks me up and he goes terminal six
today sir and i go yeah it's a nice nice
guy he's wearing a suit big you know suv
like a suburban
and i start emailing
and then make a phone call and when i
finally hang up i look up i realize
we're pretty close to the airport
so i go oh we'll make a pretty good time
he goes cause i [ __ ] drive man
and i was like shut up he goes oh you
know you see this hands on ten and two
kind of [ __ ] i don't [ __ ] around i
[ __ ] drive man okay and i go yeah and
he's like you know you see a lot of
stupid [ __ ] out there i mean all
professionalism just
come on yeah he goes you see a lot of
stupid [ __ ] a lot of times you wonder
why is this stupid [ __ ] happening and
you pull up it's cause there's a stupid
[ __ ] in the car and i was like
yeah that's true that is true you can
drop me out here if you want because i
feel
and then so i text both you guys about
that guy
two weeks go by
i see i walk out with my bag go to the
airport this time i see a sedan nice a
nice car and
i'm you know i i i hand my bag and i'm
like this this is the guy i think you
know i don't say anything he's like how
you doing put the bag in the car in the
trunk
and i get in the back and he closes the
door i go
this is a nice ride and he turns she
goes i call this the pussycar
are you kidding me i swear to god the
driver professional immediately the
[ __ ] the pussycar can i sit up front
have you guys ever done the uh the paid
for an abortion no no the denver empire
have you ever paid for no six seven i
don't know that was like early rap when
right when they when the rappers would
be like what what rhymes with lotion
right potion right ocean motion you
start listening like i listen to
backspin a lot on
xm and
every once in a while you're here when
you go how did this get recorded
me and my girl we're rubbing the lotion
and all she can do was think about
swimming in the ocean you're like this
made it you got a record deal with that
like that's horrible man that was
awesome back then though no one was
doing that no one had rhymed words in
public i guess he [ __ ] turns the car
around we're going to the stop sign that
is
40 yards from our house he goes i'm
[ __ ] a couple older [ __ ] right now
are you serious i swear to god and i go
really and he goes yeah man because i
got a theory like what is it
women in their 60s it's like the [ __ ]
comes back to life
and i go all right
and he's like he's like yeah man they
just wanna [ __ ] my [ __ ] [ __ ] and i go
cool
he goes the body's sometimes tight but
they can't hide that face man i'll
[ __ ] wrinkly i just don't look them
in the eye and i go okay
how about you go straight ahead
put that safety strategy do you like
free stuff what about sticky stuff what
if i told you if you follow us on
instagram right now link in bio we'll
send you some free sticky stuff that's
right free joke rolled stickers for
everyone who follows on instagram right
now go do it
please
please do it you said uh
you watched a new ted bundy
yeah it's interesting i
i could be very wrong he was a real
rascal that guy
he was he was man he was a roustabout he
was a knucklehead if i ever saw one um
he
uh
it's uh
so was hitler by the way
hitler had some bad ideas i remember
that you used to encourage me to do this
joke that would get me into trouble
which one the latino community oh that's
my favorite i tell people that joke all
the time
people get so mad at me man that's my
favorite i tell people that joke all the
time they go i go what's tom's act like
before i go he used to have this really
great joke about latino computers there
was it was a pl it was a place on
i want to say it was on vine or between
vine and fountain you know between
fountain and like
santa claus and it was called latino
computers that's what it said on a sign
so i the joke was uh
you used to do it real slow and kind of
real slow remember that what did you do
do you still do that style
yeah i mean i i do i do because you seem
like more fluid here and then on stage
you go into a different tom i'm usually
like i'm usually a step slower on stage
yeah yeah yeah it would go is by the way
does it still exist if you type it in i
was just looking for it now
it doesn't come out no it got deported
the story i saw
i saw a place called latino computers
um and i was like let's do the joke for
you you know you remember the joke hell
yeah i remember the joke
i saw i'm gonna do it at your pace i saw
a store called latino computers
latino computers is that really how you
really want to sell your store
like
these computers aren't really aren't
very fast but they work really hard
and then the audience would always go
and you go hey it's better than black
computers they don't work at all and
they just talk a bunch of [ __ ]
remember too on the cruise we went on
the last cruise
that they had pornography but it was too
soft
oh yeah you had to call and complain i
did and there's a filipino guy and he
goes oh
you're right i go i want it hardcore he
goes oh
no i talked to the manager and yeah no
we don't have that yeah and i go i don't
want to pay for this he's like okay
yeah they're all they're all filipino
i get to the greenhouse tavern yeah and
you know i go i had the tasting menu on
thursday and i go
i want so much
and so can you like get me some
recommendations yeah so they go you
should try this appetizer you should try
this little small plate yeah
have you had
the uh the pig's head pork yeah yeah and
i go
no and they go well you should
definitely have that and then we'll
bring this for the dessert okay so i
have the appetizer this and that
the pig's head is literally
half of a boar's head
and
because of how the how it's supposed to
be prepared they bring you
i never had that okay they bring you six
buns to make sandwiches with yeah
because it's a place it's a it's a
family style to order for like six to
eight people and they just gave and they
were just like they didn't
give you a heads up no heads up so he
puts it up and i go and i'm supposed to
do what
he's like it's delicious yeah so i just
start gorging i mean like really i'm
half ahead of the board and
force-feeding it yeah and then he's like
don't forget we got the other thing
going no no so then it's like you feel
bad you want it you want to put a dent
in it oh my god
10 minutes later i go you'll never guess
where i am i'm in my my show clothes my
jeans my shirt yeah i'm on the treadmill
in the gym because i think i'm going to
throw up if i sit down or lay down and i
walked
on the treadmill
at that hotel for i think over an hour
and i go this is just just try to help
it go down i feel like i'm gonna die if
i get off of this right now you were in
your show close still i was yeah i was
like still in like like the boots and
the [ __ ] jeans and the polar like the
collared shirt but it was worth it it's
halftime and the eagles are down
and
he's with the the you know giving the
halftime speech or whatever he walks up
there and he's just
in front in front of people is not
talking so like every you know people
are moving you know helmets and
everything right and then people are
just kind of like looking around like
what's you know he's not talking yeah
and he was just like
staring right and then he goes
they are raping your wives and your
mothers and you're watching it [ __ ]
happen and they were like what
[Laughter]
and he's like do you want your mothers
to get raped and they're like
no
[Laughter]
you want to sit around and watch that
[ __ ] that's what i'm seeing get the [ __ ]
out there were like all right
win on three yeah
did they come back and win yes they did
oh okay okay i think they were like this
guy's gonna kill us if we don't i get
high
and i uh i do voice notes like i was
talk and at the time i'll be like this
is
some high level comedy [ __ ]
that is gold and then the next day
you're listening to and you're like oh
my god i have to delete this make sure
no one ever hears this it's like
embarrassing to myself to hear myself
stone me like and then you know like
just ramble on and on thinking that i'm
coming up with some brilliant concept i
hooked up
with one of my
sister's friends
i was
hammered
like so drunk
and the next day i remember my sister
was like did you hook up with my friend
and i was like there's always that
moment where you're like you know
should i say it or not i was like yeah
and i was wondering like how she was
going to react she was like how was she
i was like what she asked yeah how was
she
that's an interesting question i know i
was like
i go yeah she was good but i was just
[ __ ] shit-faced you know and she's
like does she give good head i was like
oh my gosh that's your sister yeah like
i didn't really
think about that i don't know
a day goes by where she goes oh my god
my friend is crazy about you i was like
really and she was like yeah she was
like can't stop talking about you
i was like well you know i'm leaving so
i left
and then
she came out here here to visit and she
was like um hey do you want to go out
and i go okay
and she's with a friend a girl
and i was like oh her friend's cute
so
she was trying to hook up with me but i
was trying to hook up with her friend
and she brought me to uh i dropped her
off at a hotel and she was like do you
want to come up and i was like
uh
nah i'm good she was like i'm good she
was like
you don't want to come up and i was like
no i kept like looking at her friend she
was like okay so the next day
she comes out again with her friend
and
i'm trying to like
talk to the friend and we start talking
about uh
literature
i'm like god damn it i don't even know
any of this [ __ ] dude you know how many
photo albums i've had old school photos
i've had to sit and look at just to wait
to get any kind of right [ __ ]
attention i'm like yeah look at that
[ __ ] trip from the caribbean i'm like
how thick is this goddamn yeah and then
she's like you ever seen this one
this is just going on the trip so she's
like i'll have you read this other book
and i go
no i'm super interested though
and she was like oh i have it
and i was like great uh can i read it
she goes down i'm she's like i'm
traveling with it but it's like my
prized possession
and i was like
i'll send it back to you i promise and
she was like no i don't feel comfortable
and then i insisted i was like get it
she's like okay like i'm telling you
that i don't want to give it to you but
i just feel like i was like i thought it
was gonna you know help things progress
so
i was like oh you're gonna come
get it and she was like okay i'm like
yes this is this i thought i was gonna
close the deal
so
we go up to her room and
she gets the book i can't believe she
travels with the book
it's like her favorite book yeah it's
like worn and it's just you know there's
marks on it and stains and [ __ ]
it's like her teddy bear or something is
this [ __ ] book so i was like yeah i
would uh i can't wait to read it and she
was like
she goes i would really
be devastated
if you didn't send it back
and i go
i'll i'll definitely set it back and i
look at her and her eyes are welling oh
my god i wouldn't even be able to take
it i don't know i was like
[Music]
you're so committed you got it i know
and now i have to take it and also i'm
also realizing that
she does not have feel it for me like
it's taken me all this time she got the
she's got the feeling for the book yeah
like she and i and i'm thinking like by
showing this interest you know i'm sure
that's like what i'm thinking right like
she'll like me and this you know what
this can happen
so she's just like i would be devastated
if i didn't get this back and she hands
it to me and i can see tears in her eyes
and i'm like
i can't wait to read this
and like and then she's like cool and
she's like
like shoves me out the door she's like
boom shuts the door so now i'm like
i don't get to hook up with her the girl
i like and then i have this book and now
i have i feel the weight of
the responsibility i'm like i gotta
[ __ ] send this to her so the girl who
i had hooked up with sees me and she
goes
do you want to come up and i go no i'm
not interested because i'm now i'm just
like reading it
[Laughter]
so
i go home
i'm i obviously don't end up with either
of them
um i read this [ __ ] book over the
next
few days i read it it's a good book i
wish i
knew the name i go to the post office
fill out the whole thing
put extra stamps on it ship it
and i think i had i put a little note in
there too you know saying thank you
and then
like a week later
it comes back
wrong address no yeah
and then i just kept the book
dj dadmouth
are you committing to dj dadmouth or is
it dj
i think i feel like dadmouth is who i am
yeah i feel like
uh
i feel like that's the right dj name for
me yeah plus it's a huge shout out to
your mom's house listeners which let's
face it will be your only audience in
the beginning
i just was on rogan's podcast
um
on wednesday yeah
and uh
i was just uh drinking a lot of water
[Laughter]
with no you know just thought about it
yeah
were you hungover i wasn't i was just uh
thirsty i take it in the outer row and
uh so i was just chugging water i
checked water a lot of times it's hot as
[ __ ] out too yes
that's drinking water yeah and then uh
and then rogan was like oh [ __ ] he might
be beating sagura for water champ
you know what is what does this mean
what is he talking about
and then people started writing me and
then i didn't we we started joking back
and forth yeah yeah but i didn't i was
just joking uh very surface level yeah
yeah fun thing and then i searched the
water champ hashtag on twitter
and this [ __ ] is way deeper than i
thought
it is my favorite level of deep stupid
deep like well okay so go over this so
it's whoever drinks the most water no no
tom can explain tom explain what the
[ __ ] does it started like with something
that would maybe occupy
eight seconds of your time you know how
like there's this especially i think
like in our lifetime maybe in the last
15 years this this thing about you know
do you how much water do you drink do
you drink eight glasses a day like you
know you hear about it like oh people
always like make sure you're drinking
water
and then
it came up one time on our podcast
because
it's with my wife it was like one of
those things where
it was like yeah you work out more than
me
but like she was like but i drink more
water than you and i was like just very
matter of fact like
100 you do not drink more water than me
not even close
and then she was like absolutely i do
and so that started pushing
this ridiculous almost like competition
over
lots of episodes
like
a hundred plus
where there's well they're not all
dedicated to it but then people start to
weigh in then like there's just comments
like every time if like you say you
drink something that's not water it'll
get a mention like what the [ __ ] was
that that wasn't water you're not the
water champ then like
i mean
i mean that people started to like weigh
in on their own relationships they would
be like you know my wife says she's a
water champ she's a stupid [ __ ] she's
not like people would say crazy [ __ ]
like that wow then it became water champ
shirts then we had a water sommelier on
our show who like is a water expert he
came in with a hat that said the water
champ when he put it on my head he was
like you're the [ __ ] water champ like
he knew about it
i like that you're one of my kind of
guys which is like you know there's that
thing that i've had like 10 12 times
that gives me diarrhea
i don't know what's up i'm gonna eat it
again and guess what yeah i'm probably
gonna get diarrhea i guess yeah and then
like all the time six years later i'll
go i think that food's giving me
diarrhea that i keep eating
yes
you do this all the time to yourself and
i'll watch you i'm like dude you're
gonna get sick i just want to eat it i
just want to eat it that neighborhood's
really latino and
can i say the name of the street that i
remember yeah carondelet yeah yeah right
that name has stuck with me for some
it's such a way you always said it's
like carranza
it's actually i think you could name
someone that yeah no you could
maybe like uh
introduce my girlfriend
sounds like a first-team all-acc safety
or something that's grand hopkins right
there man
interestingly if you pull up a photo of
bezos rocket it looks just like a penis
swear to god well all rockets kind of
have a phallic this one is specific look
at this got a [ __ ] mushroom head bro
it is literally cock-shaped
that looks like a cop yeah i mean i was
kind of shocked the first time i saw
that i was like oh
jeff bezos is literally compensating for
something i mean
what if he was just like ever like he
made the design team study his dick and
he goes it's gotta look just like this
i got caught at a park when i was like
16 with a girl in a car
and uh police though it's [ __ ] your
your boner goes down real quick oh yeah
even at 16. yeah
because it was like a light and i was
like who the [ __ ] and then he was like
then when i sit up and the flashlight
kind of moves i was like oh and you see
the uniform you're like oh [ __ ] and your
boner goes
yup like i'm going to jail i beat a
[ __ ]
[Music]
you